hello everyone it was last year in the
same tournament the Isle of Man open
international tournament that Ramesh
Babu Prague nonde defeated axel Bachmann
2650 grandmaster and he does it again
this is well the same tournament its
2017 and it's round five and the prague
defeated David Howell grandmaster rated
twenty seven hundred and one at the time
this game was played so let's see this
this game and I don't know III don't
know how many GM norms young Prague has
but if I mean he seems to be winning a
lot of games he's probably very close to
achieving his Grandmaster title and I
read that he has about six more months
to break Sergei characters record to
become the youngest Grandmaster ever in
chess history so let's see this game
progress white and the how was black we
had efore c6 the caro-kann defense d4 d5
and we have E 5 at the advanced
variation Bishop to e5 Knight to f3
now e6 Bishop to e2 Knights day 7 Prague
Castle c5 c4b captures on c4 Knight to
a3
now going for that c4 pawn which can't
really be definitive well it's not
really an blacks interest to defend this
point you should go for some development
so we have Knight B to c6 Knight
captures on c4 and Knight to d5 any air
we have D captures on c5 Bishop captures
on c5 and Bishop to g5 now with an
attack on the Queen Queen to c7 we have
worked the c1 our castles we have Queen
to b3 and h6 and here we have a very
interesting move by young pregnant andhe
well the move that comes to mind here is
of course the Bishop to e3 or Bishop is
attacked and you want to get it out of
the way but rocket plays an interesting
people
he plays Knight from c-4 to e3 and he
leaves this Bishop under attack but now
he's threatening to capture how was
Bishop on c5 and well what do you do
here
it it seems that H capture some g5 is
not that bad at all for black
for example Knight captures on d5 Bishop
captures on f2 with check because this
Bishop was hanging on c5 rook captures
on f2 e captures on b5 and for example
Queen captures on d5 and well this
doesn't this seems pretty ok for black
but how all decided not to go for this
after 9:00 to e3 he played Bishop
captures on e3 we have Bishop captures
an e39 captors and III and Queen
captures and III and we have Queen to b6
Howell offers the exchange of Queens and
well Prager exchanges Queens I mean he's
a 2500 player I guess exchanging Queens
and doubling blacks be pawns isn't that
bad of a move and a3 of course now now
blocking this rook here on an open file
we have Bishop to e4 Knight to d2
attacking the bishop on d4 Knight to d4
when we have rook F 2 e1 Bishop to d5
we have Bishop to d3 now activating this
Bishop rook F 38 and now rook the c3
protecting this bishop and also may be
preparing to double up on the C file g5
by Howell and Knight to e4 and here well
you definitely don't want to allow this
night to get a hold of a square like d6
or f6 so how it captures it Bishop
captures Knight Bishop rook captures
Bishop on e4 and okay it's a pretty
equal in the game Bishop against Knight
although it's a it's it's not gonna be
that easy to make this bishop stronger
than this night we have worked to a5
before attacking the rook rook rook to
d5 and now doubling rooks on the D file
Bishop to c4 attack from the rook rook
5:37
Bishop to f1 preparing g3 and also not
allowing any checks on d1
if the knight moves Knight to f5 and now
g3 a rook to d1 King to g2 of course and
our rook to a 1 and here Bishop goes
back to d3 and now this well this rook
has infiltrated the whites position but
his
not really doing anything on a 1 as long
as this rook is guarding this pawn on a
3 that rook is well he's lost there
there isn't really any communication
between blacks rooks so we have King to
g7 and now
Prager plays a very interesting movie
plays h4 and well how captures it
captures this point although maybe maybe
a better move would be something like to
rotate to or 97 perhaps but he captures
it but now Prague has an in-between move
he plays rook to g4 with check King goes
to a 7 and now captures the knight with
check we have a capture some f5 and now
rook captures on h4 and now well this is
this is a rook ending with a same number
of points but how was be pawns are
doubled and also his F bones are doubled
and this is a completely different story
as you all know a rooks favorite meal is
a doubled pawn so we have rook to e8
rook the c7 and now well the thread is
of course capturing this F pawn with
check depending what black plays will be
capturing the beep on b7 pawn b6 pawn
it's very easy to pick up these doubled
pawns soaking to g7 not allowing this
way to check but still rock after some
b7 corrupt 85 rook captures some b6 and
rook captures an a3 and our rook
captures on h6 and okay
White is up a pawn but this advantage is
well even bigger because this F pawn is
doubled rook to e4 and we have a rook to
e7 check King to g8 a rock to h8 check
King back to g7 roof to h7 check going
for a repetition of moves but Howell
decides not to go for this
he plays King to f8 we have Rock 2h8
would check on our King to e7 rook to c8
we have Rock to be three going for that
pawn and now rook to see for defending
the pawn and also offering the exchange
of rooks
but we have rook to e5 and our rook to
h7 this pawn is now a defendant and all
is well
rook to b5 now with a double attack on
the B pawn rook to see
with check kinked Yi 6 and now rotate
sex with check f6
and now rope to see sex with check
king-tv 5 and our rook captures on f6
and how it captures the pawn rook three
captures on before and well this is kind
of the critical position of the game as
I think it was in this position that
program is the move rook C to d6 the
smoke threatens rook the e6 with
checkmate and the well only way to stop
this would be to play f4 love simply g4
again the thread is rough to e6 with
checkmate you would stop this with f3
King to g3 and now the King has to go to
e4 and now well rook checks King here
and not simply capturing this pawn with
a winning position - two extra pawns but
probably played differently after this
in this position we play the rook F to
e6 check sorry about that
we have King to d4 rook see the d6 check
rook to d5 now he exchanges rooks King
captures rook to eat - we have f4 but of
course not capturing is you don't want
to double your own pawns Rock the b3 now
f3 and now it's only a matter of time
before the King picks up this pawn rook
to b8 we have rook to e4 loud rook is
coming for the pawn or up to f8 and our
King f2 rocked f7 king he to rock f6
king de roca fate rokay for rugby a rook
to F for capturing the pawn and well we
have worked to beat three now king e - g
5 rock death I would check King before
and King f2 and in this position David
he'll resign the game as this is a
completely winning young game for white
black can't really hope for anything
here so yeah that's the game that's this
is a pregnant Aldous first victory
against the 2700 player and if any of
you has an information how many GM norms
he has collected so far please do share
in the comments
I'm very interested to hear about his
progress and I would like to thank me
house of Lenski Anthony hurt sick cody
Stanley and the guillermo gutierrez take
Sarah for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I appreciate it and yeah
that's it for this game as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank y'all for watching and I'll see
you soon